cerca de dos meses después de las
elecciones presidenciales de noviembre
de 2020 donald trump todavía no
reconocía su derrota y llamó a sus
seguidores a las calles de cara a la
jornada de votación en el congreso para
certificar la victoria de joe biden como
presidente enormes protestas en
washington 16 de enero vengan será
salvaje miles de manifestantes se
desplegaron en washington dc y caminaron
hacia el capitolio mientras donald trump
los alentaba
a todos los que estamos aquí hoy no
queremos ver nuestra victoria electoral
robada por demócratas de izquierda
radical envalentonados por los medios de
comunicación de noticias falsas eso es
lo que han hecho y lo que están haciendo
nunca nos rendiremos nunca consideremos
la victoria eso no sucederá no sucede
cuando hay un robo de por medio
poco después los manifestantes lleguen
al capítulo e invaden sus escalones
hasta entrar al recinto adentro la
sesión se suspende y la policía evacúa a
los legisladores varios representantes
como el list even se esconden en sus
oficinas estoy refugiada en mi oficina
el edificio al lado fue evacuado no
puedo creer que tengo que escribir eso
mientras tanto se alzan las voces para
pedirle a donald trump que exija el fin
del asalto tras varias horas de silencio
el ex presidente finalmente se expresa
en su cuenta de 'twitter' y pide a los
manifestantes regresar a casa aún sin
reconocer la derrota
estas fueron unas elecciones
fraudulentas pero no podemos hacerle el
juego a esta gente tenemos que tener paz
así que váyanse a casa socorro
cerca de 800 seguidores de donald trump
han sido procesados mientras que un
comité del senado investiga quién estuvo
detrás del ataque y especialmente el
papel de donald trump